>>> DONALD TRUMP AND SOME OF HIS
MOST PROMINENT SUPPORTERS HAVE
BEEN OPENLY CRITICAL OF MILITARY
OFFICIALS WHICH SOME OBSERVERS
POINT TO AS A BREAK WITH THE
PREVIOUS ORTHODOX OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
JOINING US NOW, SENIOR FELLOW
WITH THE COUNCIL OF FORMER
RELATIONS AND COLUMNIST AT "THE
WASHINGTON POST," MAX BOOT.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
YOU WROTE A PIECE CALLED, IN
CASE OUR VIEWERS HAVE NOT SEEN
THOSE COMMENTS FOR THEMSELVES, I
WANT TO PLAY THAT QUICKLY.
>> I HAVE READ MILES SATUNG,
CARL KARL MARX, WHAT IS WRONG
ABOUT HAVING AN UNDERSTANDING
ABOUT THE COUNTRY WE DEFEND.
WE ARE ACCUSING OUR
NONCOMMISSIONED OFFICERS OF
BEING QUOTE WOKE.
>> HE'S NOT JUST A BIG, HE'S
STUPID.
>> SO YOU POSE THE QUESTION WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF A DEMOCRAT HAD
SAID THAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN,
WHAT IF IT WAS A MEMBER OF THE
SQUAD, FOR EXAMPLE?
>> IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT
PEOPLE LIKE TUCKER CARLSON WOULD
BE HAVING A HISSY FIT IF IT HAD
BEEN A MEMBER OF THE SQUAD, AOC
OR ILHAN OMAR, WHO HAD CALLED
AMERICA'S TOP GENERAL A STUPID
PIG, RIGHT.
YOU CAN EASILY IMAGINE PEOPLE
LIKE TUCKER CARLSON, AND LAURA
INGRAMHAM AND SEAN HANNITY,
SAYING THEY ARE A TRAITOR.
AND YET TUCKER CARLSON GETS AWAY
WITH THIS VILE NAME CALLING AND
THERE IS NOT A HEAP OF PROTEST
ON THE RIGHT.
REMEMBER, TUCKER CARLSON WHO HAS
NEVER SERVED A DAY IN UNIFORM IN
HIS LIFE IS CALLING OUR TOP
GENERAL SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT ONLY
A GRADUATE OF PRINCETON AND
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY, BUT HAS
SERVED IN COMBAT IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN, WHO HAS RISKED HIS
LIFE, WHO HAS BEEN AWAY FROM HIS
FAMILY FOR YEARS AT A TIME,
TUCKER CARLSON IS SAYING HE'S A
STUPID PIG, AND THE RIGHT SEEMS
PERFECTLY OKAY WITH THAT.
THAT TO ME IS JUST VILE AND
UNACCEPTABLE BUT IT'S A SIGN OF
WHERE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
TODAY IN THE POST TRUMP ERA.
>> WHERE DO YOU THINK THAT SHIFT
BEGAN?
IS THERE A MOMENT THAT STICKS
OUT FOR YOU WHERE THIS SHIFT
STARTED FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WHICH HAS ALWAYS BEEN SEEN AS,
YOU KNOW, VERY PRO-MILITARY, AND
HAVING A LOT OF SUPPORT AMONG
VETERANS, EVEN AMONG ACTIVE
DUTY, OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE NOT
SAYING IT WHILE ENLISTED IS
THERE A MOMENT THAT YOU THINK
REALLY KICK STARTED THIS SHIFT
WE'RE SEEING?
>> I THINK THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF HOW DONALD TRUMP HAS
TRANSFORMED THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
FOR THE WORST.
ALL DONALD TRUMP CARES ABOUT IS
PERSONAL LOYALTY TO DONALD TRUMP
AND SO THEREFORE HE HAS BEEN
WILLING TO TRASH THE MILITARY
WHEN HE FEELS LIKE THEY'RE NOT
DOING EXACTLY WHAT HE WANTS.
IN FACT, WE HAVE HAD RECENT
REVELATIONS IN A NEW BOOK BY
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTER
MICHAEL BENDER WHO WRITES ABOUT
HOW TRUMP DEMANDED LAST SUMMER
THAT THE MILITARY CRACK THE
SKULLS OF CIVIL RIGHTS
DEMONSTRATORS, AND HE WAS
FURIOUS WHEN GENERAL MILLI, AND
OTHER GENERALS REFUSED TO GO
ALONG.
>> WE HAVE THAT.
YOU LED US INTO IT PERFECTLY,
BUT WE HAVE THAT AVAILABLE.
SO THIS COMES TO US AS YOU POINT
OUT FROM THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL'S" MICHAEL BENDER IN HIS
NEW BOOK, AND DETAILS THE
SHOUTING MATCH BETWEEN TRUMP AND
GENERAL MILLE, WE CAN SEE ON THE
SCREEN WHERE TRUMP SAID YOU'RE
IN EFFING CHARGE, WELL, I'M NOT
IN CHARGE, MILLE YELLS BACK.
YOU CAN'T TALK TO ME TRUMP SAID,
AND MILLE TURNS TO OTHERS WILL
SOMEONE INFORM HIM OF MY LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITIES.
BILL BARR STEPS IN TO SAY, HE'S
RIGHT, THE GENERAL IS RIGHT.
THAT EXCHANGE, FORGET THE FACT
THAT MAYBE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WAS NOT AWARE, RIGHT, OF WHAT
HIS ACTUAL RESPONSIBILITIES ARE,
WHAT THE LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS
COULD BE, THAT EXCHANGE WITH THE
GENERAL SAYS A LOT TO YOUR
POINT.
>> EXACTLY, AND IN THE PAST THAT
WE KNOW THAT TRUMP HAS REFERRED
TO OUR GENERALS AS DOPES AND
BABIES, THAT'S A REVELATION FROM
AN EARLIER BOOK ABOUT THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
HE'S ALSO BEEN REPORTED TO
SAYING THAT THE PEOPLE WHO GAVE
THEIR LIVES FOR THIS COUNTRY,
WHO ARE BURIED IN OUR MILITARY
CEMETERIES ARE SUCKERS AND
LOSERS.
I THINK THAT'S AN INDICATION OF
TRUMP'S WORLD VIEW, WHICH IS
THAT IT'S ALL ABOUT TRUMP, HE
CAN'T IMAGINE SOMEBODY WHO IS
HEROIC AND SELF-SACRIFICING FOR
THE NATION, AND HE CAN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY GENERALS DON'T
SIMPLY DO EVERYTHING HE WANTS,
HOWEVER UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
ILLEGAL OR IMMORAL IT MAY BE.
IT'S ABOUT PERSONAL LOYALTY TO
HIM, AND UNFORTUNATELY I THINK A
LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE NOW
COPYING THAT MINDSET.
THEY HAVE SEEN THAT TRUMP CAN
GET AWAY WITH TRASHING OUR
GENERALS, TRASHING OUR WAR DEAD,
TRASHING OUR MILITARY, AND THEY
REALIZE THAT THEIR BASE IS
PERFECTLY FINE WITH THAT. ALL
THEY CARE ABOUT IS LOYALTY TO
TRUMP AND LOYALTY TO SOME OF THE
POPULIST HARD RIGHT POSITIONS OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, AND SO THE
BASE IS NOT GOING TO INFLICT ANY
COST ON THEM FOR DISPARAGING THE
MILITARY, AND THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
SO MANY ON THE RIGHT NOW,
INCLUDING FOLKS LIKE SENATOR TED
CRUZ, TUCKER CARLSON, LAURA
INGRAMHAM, CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ, SO MANY OTHERS WHO ARE
TRASHING AND MOCKING THE U.S.
MILITARY FOR SUPPOSEDLY BEING
WOKE AND EMBRACING CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, AND TRUMP IS JOINING IN
THAT, TALKING ABOUT WOKE
GENERALS.
IT'S COMPLETE NONSENSE, BUT IT
FEELS LIKE THE RIGHT IS NOW
WAGING THIS WAR ON THE U.S.
MILITARY, WHICH IS THE LAST
THING I WOULD HAVE EVER IMAGINED
HAVING GRO